[Music]
now in this program for years we have
documented night after tonight how much
of the media is just simply an extension
of the Democratic Party they are one
team coordinating the same political
messages manufacturer crisis they even
use the same words an echo chamber
repeat the same talking points and
tonight it is on display more than ever
after the leak of a recent New York
Times employee Town Hall to slate where
the paper's leadership they came clean
about how anti-trump their agenda really
is all this breathless hysteria and all
that they preview all the conspiracy
theories they pushed all fake news
narratives are up next
well it's like I've said journalism it's
been dead and buried since 2007 I said
it on this program their credibility is
in crisis they don't really have any
credibility and especially after two and
a half years all the major networks to
cable networks New York Times Washington
Post yeah they went with the biggest
lying conspiracy theory hoax in modern
political history and they never
admitted they're wrong and even The
Times is now admitting that they went
all in on the collusion delusion with an
executive editor Dean but Kate telling
employees that once the rucks russia
hoax unraveled the story became quote
trickier before adding quote we built
our newsroom to cover one story and we
did it truly well no they didn't now
they were proven wrong they were
disappointed by Muller now we have to
regroup shift resources and emphasis to
take on a different story Oh what does
that mean a different story
it means they spent years pushing their
conspiracy theories they're Russian lies
misinformation propaganda all to help
the Democrats and they failed miserably
with their lies and conspiracy theories
now they have to find a new fake news
story narrative to try and continue to
bludgeon the president they're no better
than you know these angry agenda-driven
keyboard warriors on social media in
their basements we're in their underwear
spewing their hate online all day every
day well the New York Times is no better
this is the new extreme radical press in
America hate Trump every second every
minute every
every day which apparently will now be
retreating to the old Democratic talking
point they want to now go through and
basically tattoo on Donald Trump he's a
racist racist racist
I guess because stormy stormy stormy
impeachment impeachment a collusion
collusion Russia Russia Russia failed
because at the same event yet one New
York Times staffers say quote these
conversations about what is racist
what isn't racist I just feel like
racism is in everything why don't you
call out the Democratic Party that
before adding it's less about the
individual instances of racism it's sort
of how we're thinking about racism and
white supremacy as the foundation of all
of our systems in the country to which
the executive editor the New York Times
responded that race is going to be a
quote huge part of the American story in
the next year in quote terms of not only
african-americans in their relationship
with Donald Trump but Latinos and
immigration of course this just confirms
everything we have been telling you
about the corrupt media mob the
anti-trump conspiracy theory media their
desire to paint all Republicans all
conservatives racist sexist homophobic
xenophobic Islamophobic they want dirty
air water killed children throw granny
over the cliff after your feeder for a
year with dog food or cat food it's not
every two years of four years anymore
this unhinged lie it is a slander
against conservatism army conservative I
find all racism anti-semitism repugnant
have they called out a lot of the
Democratic Party's history we've given
the history on this show and I'll do it
again to remind them maybe tomorrow
night but this is all they do and the
Democrats and of course their friends in
the media they all work in concert with
one another because beyond Russia the
lie they never admitted they were wrong
never admitted they lied are they ever
going to return those Pulitzer Prizes I
doubt it
they're also spinning now in another
direction and they're telling us ahead
of time listen to their new talking
points about an economic recession
that's another thing talk down the
economy watch put it into perspective is
the president right when he says the
recessions not on the way
he's not right but a recession is okay a
recession is a normal part of economic
activity President Trump is attempting
to downplay growing concerns that the US
economy could be headed for a recession
this morning recession and re-election
President Trump
insisting he has no concerns about the
economy after that 800 point plunge Josh
isn't the Fed cutting rates now just
going to make the next economic downturn
worse what's your prediction I've been
hoping for a recession people hate me
for it but yeah it would get rid of
Trump so you shouldn't hate me for it I
mean recessions are really bad people
lose their jobs and I know and we and we
shouldn't which it's worth it that's
gonna make it tough recession how does
Trump losses I mean I think that that's
what I wish that I know it's Trump there
you go let's have a recession let's talk
down the economy because Muller didn't
work our own Pete hagseth may have some
the best tweeting quote verse it was
Russia Russia Russia racism racism
racism recession recession recession
stormy stormy collusion collusion in
peach and Peach
same thing manufactured crisis
manufactured crisis this program we are
committed to exposing all of the media
conspiracy theories lies every hoax
every besmirched meant that they tell
the American people to divide this
country real conservatives they deplore
racism from the person that has done
more for the employment situation for
minorities in America the policies that
have worked best are the policies of
Donald J Trump fact maybe they should
put that in their paper one day the
collusion delusion covington look what
they did to that kid Nicholas Sandman
look what they did to justice Cavanaugh
look at the lies that there's still
presidential candidates passing on the
conspiracy theory over Ferguson ignoring
the biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal in our nation's history they
have chosen to act as nothing but
partisan activists state-run democratic
radical socialist extremist TV radio and
yeah print instead of being serious
investigators they've chosen to put fake
news fake narratives conspiracy theories
over facts and chosen to attack anyone
who will do
err to call out their lack of ethics and
objectivity will continue to give you a
front-row seat to all this corruption
and the media we will hold them
accountable we'll continue to expose
them but frankly they expose themselves
joining us now with more Fox News
contributor Sarah Carter author of swamp
wars conservative columnist Jeffrey Lord
Sarah for two and a half years we've had
an unsolvable cast both you and Jeff
have been a part of it
Greg John Solid the the tons Victoria
ton Singh Joe digenova judge pure we
have told the American people the truth
within the next two months I'm pretty
confident we're going to be proven right
on a level that might take away the
breath of the American people and shock
the conscience but these lies get told
they don't apologize don't revise and
extend it'll make a correction or
apology they just go to the next thing
and they're telegraphing it Shawn it's
actually shocking to me I remember when
I first started as a young reporter at
the Daily Bulletin in California the
first thing my editor said is you don't
shape a narrative you let the story come
to you as an investigator you go out you
see it you collect the evidence and then
you report it to the American people or
to the local community that I was
covering and when you see what the New
York Times has done this is the reason
why they didn't want to know the truth
Shawn the New York Times did not want to
know the truth because had they wanted
to know the truth they would have been
right there with us all along uncovering
the same information that we uncovered
throughout the last two and a half years
on your show that is John Solomon and I
and others who have been reporting on
this what Devin Nunez discovered what
Lindsey Graham discovered the New York
Times would have been there but they
wanted to shape the narrative and I'm
going to tell you what's absolutely
frightening right now what really is
stunning is that they're gonna try to
shape the narrative on racism this is
extraordinarily dangerous particularly
coming from the New York Times that ran
an anti-semitic an anti-semitic cartoon
globally with President Trump and
Netanyahu they actually had to end their
cartoons in their newspaper because of
this now they're gonna try to shape this
racist agenda and I want the American
people to realize that this is
absolutely wrong
says backwards the executive editor
should be ashamed should be fired should
be fired from the New York Times and we
should get back to reporting real
stories and letting the American people
saw what the evidence is it's not gonna
happen and and Jeff you've been you
worked for the Reagan administration if
you're if you say you are a conservative
and you're white supremacists or a
racist ah nobody that I know in
mainstream conservatism supports you
period end of sentence this is a big lie
usually every two and four years now
it's everyday that's right Sean what the
New York Times is engaged in is the
Stalin izing of American history you
know this is you've talked about this
this is something Rush Limbaugh has
talked about for years of the left
wanted to do a total rewrite of American
history and remake the story that were
founded in racism and it's all about
race etc etc it said where were they in
the 64 exactly Sean Voting Rights Act in
65 exactly it's exactly Sean and it's
variously I've read the New York Times
pieces near so-called 1619 project there
is an assala Terry mention that slavery
and segregation were the party of
Democrats I got it but I'll say this
imagine if Donald Trump said that the
former Klansmen KKK bird was his mentor
or J William Fulbright was his mentor
like Hillary and Bill did